hey folks i'm international master
christian kavitsky
here with the recap for the 2020 u.s
junior
championship so this tournament just
concluded
yesterday it's the second in the series
of the us championships that are all
being held
online this october of course we had the
previous u.s girls
junior championship and if you missed my
recap video for that you can find it on
the st louis chess club youtube channel
here
and uh yeah so the us jr was a really
exciting event once again
nine rounds all rapid 25 plus five
and the tournament i mean was incredibly
strong it was all
gm's and iams some of the best juniors
in the world
jeffrey zhang the top seed number two
junior in the world number five
player in the us so really really uh
strong strong field in fact jeffrey and
the number two seed sam sevien
are also going to be playing in the
actual u.s championship
coming up at the end of the month but
the tournament was actually won by
the third seed grand master uh john
burke
who was actually always kind of behind
jeffrey in the event i would say zhang
was leading
basically throughout the event and only
caught up to him at the very
end to force a rapid playoff that he
actually ended up winning in pretty
dramatic fashion so let's take a look at
what happened
uh like i mentioned jeffrey i think was
uh basically dominating the field for
for
most of the event uh savion had kind of
a rough start and he was always trying
to
to catch up uh but jeffrey was playing
really solid and he was winning a lot of
games in the end game just kind of
grinding his opponents down
this is a good example of that this is
jeffrey's game against uh international
master
uh christopher yu and in the same game
with black jeffrey has been
putting a lot of pressure in this rook
end game so far white has been holding
but here christopher makes a pretty
uh typical and decisive uh mistake and
he plays the move king to e3
allowing black to go for this king and
pawn end game that ends up being
very very favorable for for black here
with the more active
uh position uh instead why needed to
just give this check on e2 and just
continue
playing the game with rooks on the board
uh rook end games are kind of
notoriously
drawish so even though white is still a
little bit worse here the position was
quite
holdable but the pressure kind of leads
white to
making this mistake he didn't have a lot
of time uh on his clock at this point
uh and now jeffrey pounces he goes for
the end game plays king to d5
white plays king to c3 how do i try to
take the opposition with king d3 then
black and for instance play this move a3
white's king will have to start walking
over towards the pawn
uh to take it and we kind of get the
same line we'll see in the game where
black's king is actually going to go for
the kingside pawns and end up winning
uh the race so things will basically
transpose
instead why play the immediate king c3
uh black plays king to e4
in b4 and now the players have a pawn
race
i'm sure jeffrey had already calculated
this all out
now at this point white plays king b4 i
think his best chance was to play
king to b5 um but the problem is after
black
takes the pawn and we get our pawn race
uh well both sides will be queening at
the same time
but black's pawn is going to be queening
with
a check so this is probably why uh white
didn't want to put his king on the b5
square
uh we would end up with this queen and
pawn end game where black is probably
going to win
the second pawn here and this one is
more or less
uh losing so this would have been the
best chance but still
losing endgame for white instead white
played king
b4 uh now jeffrey takes a
and he could go for the same kind of end
game with just making a queen
and trying to get two extra pawns but
actually jeffrey finds a really
smart idea here to play king to e5
stepping his king inside
of the the square of the pawn here so
that now if white keeps pushing the pawn
black's king will be able to simply
catch up
and blockade it and then of course
black's two pawns are just winning the
game
uh so white tried king c5 to cut the
black king off
but now king e6 again he's threatening
to
come back and just stop white's pawn in
its tracks so white played king c6
but now when black pushes the f-pawn
both sides end up promoting at the same
exact time
but because white was forced to put his
king on c6
the game ends with a skewer as if white
promotes here
black will play queen h1 check winning
the queen so
the king here just ends up being very
unfortunately placed
and that was game over so that was kind
of jeffrey's uh
road to the top i think grandmaster
burke actually had a very
different road his games seem to be a
lot sharper a lot more
dramatic and he definitely showed a lot
of really good uh preparation in the
tournament
as well i think getting a lot of big
advantages out of the uh
opening one of his most impressive games
i thought was against uh international
master
josh shang here burke is playing black
in the position
and in this position white decides to
take on g6
uh fully grabbing the the pair of
bishops
and on g6 black decides to recapture uh
fg which is certainly tempting to open
up the rook
on df file but a little bit
anti-positional of course because black
is capturing
away from the center well white plays g5
and h4 here continuing very ambitiously
and if white could get away with this
then strategically this would actually
be pretty problematic for blacks knight
which is now on the side of the board
but with zero prospects of getting
back into the game all of its squares
are covered meaning if y can just fully
dominate and restrict the knight
and black will have a really really
tough time in the position and it's up
to black to kind of justify his position
with active play
which burke uh manages to do quite quite
well
goes knight c5 queen f7 lining up on the
f file
rook h2 and here comes the shot knight
to g3
making use of this knight that was just
on on the side of the board
now of course if y takes queen takes f1
check is going to be really painful
white played bishop h3 and now the
attack continues queen f3 black doesn't
back down at all now when f takes g3
queen takes g3
the rook is hanging and e3 is hanging of
course white is in check and white is
just losing a lot of material
here so the knight is still untouchable
and that means that black's
uh queen here that is now preventing
white's king
from castling is kind of also
untouchable as well
white played rook to d1 and now e4
another really really strong
and i would say non-obvious move to open
up the bishop
for white here on b2 but black just
correctly judges that the fight for the
light squares is kind of more important
here
white pushes d4 knight e3 check rick
takes d3 e takes d3
and here actually white misses one
moment to make the game
uh quite complicated he could have
inserted the move bishop to e6 check in
this exact position
and then after king to h8 then take the
pawn on d3
with the difference here that now rick a
e8 is going to be met with the move
d5 and then white secures the bishop on
e6 has a strong bishop on v2
and would have some very very reasonable
compensation i would say for
the exchange instead in the game white
ends up taking the pawn
immediately but now after rook to e8 the
bishop on h3 doesn't activate itself
and white is forced to go really really
passive here with bishop c1
defending against possible threats of
rook takes e3 and so on
black goes rookie four here knight to f5
and now white's position is basically
just collapsing black has the
exchange and the attack on the e-file
and
after queen d1 knight takes d4 nice
tactic the game was
basically over so these two players
ended up
meeting in uh the final which was quite
interesting actually because
burke actually lost to zhong in round
one of the event
and then had to basically play catch up
uh the whole time
uh but before we get to the playoff i
want to show one of the more interesting
games of the event as well
uh this was i am christopher you against
grandmaster brandon jacobson
and this was a really interesting game i
wasn't sure exactly
what happened here because here
christopher playing white
makes this move queen to f4
and he did it after a little bit of
thought
um well black goes f6 hitting the bishop
on
g5 and kind of asking the question to
white where is the bishop going
the bishop h4 there's going to be g5
fork
winning the piece and on bishop h6 is
played in the game
black again has g5 and
white has to part ways with the bishop
now this is actually kind of okay for
white had they found the move queen to
f5
with idea bishop takes h6 and d6 this is
kind of a computery line the point is
now
okay the pawn is untouchable because of
the bishop on d5 that's hanging
but otherwise white has threats at
bishop d5 check and d7
and rookie 7 and queen takes f6 and
basically it's a pretty strong attack
and white has a ton of
uh compensation so i don't know if
christopher uh
willingly was looking for some kind of
sacrifice
like this um because in the game on g5
he ends up playing queen takes d4
bishop takes h6 and then pushing d6
here and this one didn't quite feel like
it was going to be enough
compensation for white but of course
these positions are
really really difficult to defend and
often much harder
for the player defending because they
have to deal with all these threats
they have to make sure they're not
blundering anything whereas the attacker
can just continue to just make active
moves trying to pose problems
and it's a much easier game to play you
don't have to worry about your king at
all
here i think had black played rook 88 he
might have had uh
some chances here of getting an edge
this does feel like a really
natural move but instead black chose
bishop to d7
which also kind of makes sense just to
immediately blockade the pawn
but now christopher finds very strong
move rookie seven
hitting the bishop on d7 kind of forcing
black to take
d takes e7 and this pawn on e7 ends up
being
an incredibly powerful asset for white
now let's take a look at what
might happen here uh if the bishop moved
out of the way with bishop to e6
then we have queen d a check and black
will be losing the rook uh in case of
bishop e8 then why would again go queen
d8
because the rook is hanging and there's
actually no way of defending the rook on
e8 black would be forced to take the
queen
and white would make a new queen winning
the rook and now would be
exchange up winning the game
same thing on bishop c6 why would just
go queen d a check
and because the rook on aid is hanging
black is again losing the rook one way
or
the other black could try to defend the
bishop with a move like queen to b5
but then white would play a4 and it's
all kind of falling apart
queen c6 is unavailable on queen f5
white would go g4
we have this kind of nice geometry where
the queen can't go to e6 either because
of bishop d5
and black would be losing the bishop on
d7
so brandon makes the kind of last move
that makes sense in the position queen
to a4
defending the bishop and challenging
white's queen on d4
um and here i'm generally i would just
expect something like queen takes f6 or
bishop d5
check uh but christopher finds really
really strong move rook to d1
fantastic down a piece but he's
willingly
trading queens because he sees that on
queen takes d4
rook takes d4 the bishop on d7 is
hanging
and rick d8 is still a monster threat
meaning that even in the end game this
pawn ends up being
a decisive factor so bishop e8 could be
played but then rook to d8 and black is
just losing the game
uh brandon was forced to play rook to e8
giving up the bishop on
d7 so that the pawn wouldn't promote but
now there wasn't really a lot of hope uh
in this endgame for black white ends up
with a lot of extra material
very active rook and um yeah with two
extra pawns and rooks on the board
the opposite color bishops certainly
provide black some drawing chances and
it did take christopher uh quite a few
moves to to win the game but
of course the players are playing on
increment and in time trouble
um so yeah the technique can always be
and always be better
but overall really really great
attacking game by
christopher so that brings us to the
playoff match which was two games 10
plus two
between the leaders jeffrey zhang and
john berg
and now the story of this playoff was
kind of interesting i would say jeffrey
kind of had the initiative and the
better position uh in
every single game for instance in game
one
uh jeffrey had this position as black
and
is basically kind of dominating here he
has the better structure the more active
pieces
uh and white has a lot of weaknesses
like the c4 pawn and
pawn on a2 um but what happens here is
that jeffrey ends up
rushing a little bit he goes knight to
a4
uh y plays rook to b7 knight c3 check
king e1 takes his pawn on a2 he wins the
pawn but then after the trait of rooks
white goes rook to b6 and all of a
sudden white has this kind of annoying
counter play
against black's pawns on the sixth rank
the engine still thinks black has some
chances of being better here but down on
time jeffrey wasn't able to
really make anything happen here and
just repeated moves and
made a draw instead of going knight a4
though
black probably would have been better
off just trying to slowly
improve the position of course always
easier said than done when you are
under a minute on the clock but
something like playing h5
h4 or even king to e6 and to d7 just to
cover the c6 pawn in advance
um would have kept things really really
difficult for
for white hair and black would have had
nearly decisive advantage
uh in the second game jeffrey also had a
pretty uh serious edge
in the end game um but john defended
well
and due to the you know rapid time
control it's
can be hard to win these uh really
really
technical and kind of marginal uh
positions
um but he was doing much better here as
white finding this move e5
taking on d6 and uh
eventually trading into an endgame
with same colored bishops here
where white has a pretty sizable
advantage just due to the activity of
his king and his bishop
just having more space in the position
but here after h6 jeffrey again kind of
rushes it a little bit with the move
c5 instead as uh yasser was pointing out
in the commentary
um would have been much better for white
to just start pushing his eight pawn
first
a4 a5 bishop d3 pushing b5
and actually trying to create a distant
pass pawn on the queen side
playing b5 and then maybe even one day
b6
um for example king e7 white can just
keep pushing
keep pushing and then he can create a
passport on this side of the board he
can create a passport
on the king side as well and would have
really really good chances of winning
this game instead after c5
uh black just kind of ignored white here
with the move g5
takes takes was played bishop f3 and
black just shuffled
and white was never able to make a pass
pawn against black
just keeping the bishop on d7 and e8
and the players eventually drew this
game as well
so two draws in the playoff means we go
into
the armageddon game uh jeffrey john got
white in this game with five minutes
against
john burke's four minutes but keep in
mind there was no
increment for this armageddon game as
increment would just give too big of an
advantage
to the player trying to hold with draw
odds in this case
uh burke so this game started off
really interesting but eventually just
kind of devolved into
a time scramble as both players were
under 10 seconds
and just trying to make moves really
really uh quickly
so jeffrey john again started off uh
really well i would say he had a nice
position here
and he ends up getting a pretty serious
edge with this move knight to h5
um trading off the knights forcing g6
going queen c5
and now white is going after this weak
pawn on d4
uh black tri queen b6 queen d6 was
played there should be six
c5 and white is winning upon here as
otherwise this
d pawn would be taken said black goes
queen d8 white takes on c6
and after a couple more moves here white
ends up going for
this end game after queen e7
takes takes with an extra pawn big big
advantage here
for jeffrey i mean he really did
everything right in this position
um but unfortunately spent a little bit
too much time
doing all this and of course as they
were making these moves you know the
clock was ticking down
the clock was ticking down and here
comes again kind of a rash move
b4 allowing rook c4 i think this is
probably just the blunder as
white loses a pawn here but despite
losing the pawn
jeffrey keeps fighting and he keeps
pushing
and again manages to create a winning
position but the problem is of course he
just spends
too much time doing it and eventually
the game does go into this
really really messy time scramble where
even though white is completely winning
he still has to make
a lot of moves to actually uh win the
game
and even though jeffrey managed to
actually
end up promoting his pawn um by that
point i think they were down to about
like
10 seconds each again without increment
they're both
uh pre-moving a bunch and uh eventually
jeffrey ends up flagging see how many
king moves he had to make
just to win the game and then has to try
to make
the second queen but eventually loses on
time and
it was game over i know burke wasn't too
pleased about
uh winning in this fashion but both
players you know had
an amazing event uh they were tied after
nine rounds they had a really intense
two game
rapid playoff and of course armageddon
had to decide things at the end of the
day
so congrats to grandmaster john burke
who ends up winning the uh 2020 u.s
junior championship uh he will be
qualifying for next year's
u.s championship which uh hopefully run
in person and be an incredible event and
coming up next is the u.s senior
championship which is actually starting
uh saturday tomorrow at 1 p.m local
central time and that's going to be a
really exciting event i'll be back here
on youtube
with the recap at the end of that and
hopefully you guys will
tune in so until then take care